welcome back to real thoughts sorry been
a while I think it's been like you know
like three four months or something like
that so sorry about that uh we ran out
of real thought just don't fake shit but
going through on Facebook and I said
which ones would you like us to talk
about that you were a couple that we
have and I'm like well how have we not
talked about that and one of them what
life is beautiful yeah well one of my
favorites oh I thought you were just
saying it's a phrase you mean like yeah
actually I feel like you could probably
pick apart that one is that the sumif
list is always my standard go-to and I
just I'm sick of men like it's beautiful
it's like supposed to be corny in the
first half that's like the idea yeah I
will say this if it just topped at the
halfway point of the I think most open
that that was cute why's everyone going
nuts like all the second half that's
where everything kind of changes a
little bit let's do a brilliant segue
from that into Judge Dredd problem
justice is beautiful yes yeah so Cuomo
so amazing first of all it's actually a
pretty beautiful looking film in terms
like the production and the money thrown
at it and like one seems straight off
right now I love this me yeah I mean
like but legit good things about it I
mean even like even though it's not
practical I think the Judge Dredd outfit
looks friggin cool I mean it's like no
one would be able to move around as a
cop but it well it's definitely comic
book II in the comic book II way not the
dark gritty graphic novel so yeah fight
crime
same thing but it looks cool it's
definitely more of a um a little
cartoony like but but that's fine it's
it's more of a comic book cartooning at
the dark you know did you ever read the
comic at all uh not much I only read a
little bit too yeah so I didn't have
that much to go so I wasn't
I didn't know me used to be yeah going
into it I didn't know jack shit about
Judge Dredd and I left it just fine but
I think it's one of those things where
I'm sure if you were attached to the
property just like I was attached like
spider-man and spider-man three can burn
in hell or amazing spider-man spider-man
3 is probably I still hate spider-man 3
more that was pretty tough but I think
then we had a lot of problems too though
I think with this one though like going
in like I don't know do we hit that
Phase II or that stage where we started
to like bad movies out if we got to that
stage yet so I didn't know what to think
of it when I saw I think we were kind of
there but I think we just recognized it
was immensely entertaining yeah like why
you might believe you weren't taking
this serious no maybe that's what the
filmmakers intended I I doubt that when
you cast Rob Schneider as your sidekick
no Rob Schneider is the key he's Jar Jar
Schneider is the key to all of this he
will create the Empire I always want to
try and gift nighters some credit when
he's legitimately actually legitimately
like him in this movie I cuz because he
just is causing so much annoyance still
Sylvester Stallone but there's an eye I
just enjoy why I just enjoy watching it
there's maybe three lines where I
chuckled a bit at him and you know I'll
give you know that credit but it's one
of those rooms just like yeah just like
oh really we're gonna go do this he's
like such the wormy little you know well
yeah that's the point you know as
demolition man doesn't even count cuz he
hardly he's got what five lines and then
ya know he's fine but I mean he's he's
barely in it I think it's just he so has
no right to be in this movie
and I somehow just have to respect that
somehow he's there just completely
blowing this movie to bed well what's my
to is that like maybe it's that maybe
it's patrol in me that just loves Rob
Schneider in this movie because it's
like
it's trying to a certain degree the
ticket says and then here's Rob
Schneider they're like oh it's gonna be
bad it was funny I'm reading a book on
this will connect trust me I'm reading a
book on the making the x-men cartoon and
they were talking about when they were
doing the first episode they have you
know Jubilee she's like the newcomer and
she's going to come across the x-men and
anytime she has a question like the
audience does they answer it and at
first it looks like Shania is gonna do
that like he's the one being introduced
to this new world and he's trapped until
this war zone it's like okay he kind of
has a purpose but he's then got rid of
everything he says he comes back yeah
only to be the comic relief except for
one moment where he has like he's no
robot he's not like that was though that
was Winston basically and Ghostbusters
was he was to be the audience and so I
feel like those kings - blue-collar
everyman LED yeah no he's he's not
Winston like that they're good actors
and then I had no plans tonight
I love Bernie Hudson so it just again he
just did no right to be there no right
to it in like and we'll be sorry they
start filming they're like you know what
it's - they don't smile and I throw in
somebody laughs yeah you know comic
relief yeah and it's really fast and it
makes the movie even dumber and for that
I actually really enjoy like the feel of
this film in terms of like just how
corny it is not a Rob Schneider guy
anything personally against it was good
he has a show I think I Netflix I able
to see about it I heard it's supposed to
be good but yeah I think personal
against him but this is like deuce
Bigalow does not do it for me so but I I
actually legitimately enjoy him in this
movie like when he's on screen I'm not
cringing I'm actually just kinda like
he's totally recognizable and they get
Stallone who's just at the height of
doing his shtick I mean this is Jesse's
Eddie load or dick a - stickiest I stand
still oh it is Stallone at his slighest
yeah
uh-oh what's it maybe I mean here's what
are we just playing a caricature of
himself Eddie yeah
rate at the time where he was I knew
you'd say that he was already kind of
doing this I always say the Rocky films
are a perfect representation of his
career everything that happens in those
rocky down the toe and everything I mean
this is a solid rocky four oh this is
rocky four we're in the minute yeah we
are in your boy and rocky floor in this
film then we actually were in Rocky four
yeah cuz I think he's still trying in
Rocky for the rest of the movies just
bats but he like he's trying with this
one it's just like it's gonna be this
kind of thing we haven't gone to Rocky
five yet we're even he's tired of the
stick but we're in a solid four where
he's still thrown his all into this and
he's just like it's freaking crazy won't
they ever make a temper tantrum
attendant uh she made great it was him
and Wesley Snipes like made that movie
because they were so into it that's the
same thing here he's just like this is
not him disinterested he's throwing his
all in it yeah I mean it's just cheese
but he like he's completely giving it a
hundred and ten percent and that's why
the movie is really entertaining and
it's funny they don't you know the
villain is a scientist is that he says
Armand de sant Armando Sanchez and you
know he's supposed to be his brother and
everybody in the movie says you two look
alike yeah some of those things were
it's like no no like it's one of those
things where it's like I wouldn't think
that looking at but when it's implanted
in your head I'm like I can't kind of
see it just take him on Santa stretch
his face I can't serve that this well I
guess part of it is he's so overacting
to that between two over actors like now
I see the resemblance cuz barking
they're line yeah cuz everything I mean
he could be a very you know good subtle
act I mean his eyes adjust when we come
across yeah it's amazing it's just Dalia
me you swear his eyeballs are gonna pop
out of his sock yeah whereas some
hospital it looks like Stallone's are
too but they're also like half awake
side oh yeah some reason trying to give
that credibility you know this is one of
those movies does it bill
like he gives it credit but the movies
it's the same thing he did in force
awakens I
I felt like that was the same character
and force awakens laundry yes all this
was all the same planet and he's been
wandering the desert and all of a sudden
as I heard but I he gives it no he gives
it credibility like yeah he's not that
the thing is he's he's completely he's
completely selling it as a credible
actor he's not doing the eddie redmayne
thing of like I'm just gonna be crazy
British actor and completely be
over-the-top it's he's underplaying it
compared to everybody else in the movie
yeah
and these honestly I think that's why it
works is just because if you added
another crazy person yeah yeah like you
needed that stabilizing sight away the
excess to play her she is a you know a
little more of the grounded person - you
got the her sidekick whatever his name
was the kind of care even though
Schneider's supposed to be the hacker
but I just call him Robin cuz he reminds
me of Chris O'Donnell from I forgot it's
just like you don't know my problem is
when you're looking you've also got
Hershey I'm like V not quite Sandra
Bullock because I swear to God whenever
I think of these two movies I'm like
which one is no Sandra bug was very
distinct and demolition man with this
one I mean she doesn't find in Judge
Dredd but she's cool a just the tough
chick you know and her psychic is just
the kind of you know they feel like
similar movies and they both came out oh
they don't too long
definitely they both have Stallone
they're both of the future they built it
so much later it's almost like wit you
know how they by that very extreme what
do you know how studio don't put up what
you know how Studios do that how that
one year we had like a tornado
miniseries and then twister and next
year we had two meteor movies and the
volcano is I feel like this was like
they're just like uh-uh they're gonna do
judge it's like alright let's do our own
ripoff and somehow through the grace of
God they got Sylvester Stallone for both
of us like this happen
this is supposed to be the Sylvester
Stallone knockoff and Sylvester Stallone
said yes exhale start is own porn
I knew you'd spray that you know and I'm
trying to think what is about
like films like this but then like other
you know like I don't even know I'll say
2% because it's popping in my head uh
you know like passionate sci-fi films
you know future they're also pretty
goofy but are just not as much fun
Jupiter sending just was boring it was
also way too long I think I was eluded
the plots to both Judge Dredd and
demolition man are stupid simple is like
it or even something like Phantom Menace
or something is that a lot of them seem
more concerned about their world
building and you know the story we want
create the backstory of this world and
what's going on and this was another one
if you start cutting out like half of
those boring speeches and the Galactic
Senate it's like you could milk
something a little more entertaining out
of it well because for the sake of being
complet I think the reason this is fun
is that it's also its focus more on
character even though their total
stereotypes and their totally insane it
is just pushed to the absolute extreme
of their stereotypes and that's where
the focus is it's like there is talking
about the story in the world and that's
not left out but that's where the fun is
is these people with these extreme
personalities working off each other
even though it's it's totally nuts it's
the fifth element thing I think if that
meant stupid movie but yeah bullshit
look they even look kind of like that's
what surprised me though yes kind of
dark fit though most of the effects in
dread in dread I thought for the most
part held up pretty good yeah like
really I was wondering too there's a
couple of bad madding shots but I'm like
for the most one was like wow I really I
am robot oppression and everything it's
like they CG it not even thinking about
it you know wait which again I get it
you want to save on money and stuff like
that but I mean it's like they built it
there that looks really there you take a
shot we mentioned how CGS okay one of
the reasons we bring that up is because
it is not done as much anymore and the
reason they don't do practical as much
as see G's because not only the CG
usually save money uh it is also
extremely difficult extremely hard to do
that's why we mentioned because we say
hats off to you that must have been
incredibly the best CGI is the CGI you
don't notice and it happens all the time
Mad Max is one of my greatest examples
there's like all practical pranks
practical effects there's CGI all over
their movie probably in every shot yeah
you don't notice it though
that's where CJ's fest button you make
it the focus of like we're just gonna
CGI everything like it just doesn't work
by and large occasionally you'll find
one that works but it's guys I feel like
it's gotta be realistic like Sin City or
actually Jungle Book was pretty damn
impressive I did not know it's all in a
studio that was my favorite thing about
them that actually blew my mind
you know it's one of those things where
after I saw it I was like I don't get
why people are loving this movie and
somebody mentioned that I'm like no
you're kidding and when I saw the
footage I'm like good god you know like
that's amazing so so there are times it
can be really really great and in that
sense you know kind of need it I can see
why they did that especially when you're
acting with a kid actor but yeah I a kid
with CGI you a completely
computer-generated computer voice
synthesized actually is this every
single aspect okay I'm just gonna say I
was like I don't remember being that bad
but he's just the kid and you're where
we're getting onto different stuff here
but you're also the CG great movies
movies worthy of respect and recognition
have cannibalism in them and this one
did not disappoint
yeah those weird they were the religious
cannibals or I don't even know what
their story was it was so crazy I do
remind that one guy I know it reminds me
of my trip through Appalachia let me
tell you I do remember that one guy who
was like half metal and he had a little
hooker or a knife or whatever and stuff
like that when I read the comics I
remember seeing that guy by god that was
like identical like he just came
off the page and onto the big screen and
I was on those things runs like wow you
you got that so there are a lot of times
where they like really captured what the
comic looked like probably not the tone
from what I hear I hear the reboot Dredd
was a lot better at that which I still
haven't seen I gotta see that stupid one
so much I'm sure the other ones great I
just love the stupidity original um yeah
Acharya I think what I'm trying to think
like the plot was about clones like he's
a super super I never remember what the
story is I remember that he's framed and
his brother is framing him and then
after them like yeah what was going to
create an army of judges gonna be like
you're such clones and he was gay yeah
like which it would honestly forgettable
honestly looking at it considering how
the justice system was working to begin
with because Dredd is the embodiment of
everything that's wrong with it I was
just like you're really just it's this
is a lateral move like really Rika was
doing I was like I don't see how this is
that bad considering what they have
already but the code been like an
interesting commentary there or whatever
they don't like the service droid is
your friend yeah I do like that babe
please move out the way of the service
joy please the servitor is your friend
please let your friend go by though he's
like the gun like that that bit is funny
but yeah it just the sets too and
everything it's like there's a legit
there's still I feel that was very
stupid no it's it's it's I feel that
universe exists and I like that about
movies where I'm like it doesn't feel
too fake I feel like I could live there
and I'm not sure I'd want to live there
but I feel like I could like you know
what is Hannibal yeah in this extreme
future where if the characters are
extremely catchy more extreme I'm Eric
it cuts to like whatever the center of
justice or whatever and it's a giant
eagle like this and that is so
ridiculous it's like of course that's in
this world
oh yes it is and nothing really felt out
of place I'm like no this is where I
should be the only thing a poner don't
think that I'll place
yeah this is a film with on the coup
there's a fight on the corner of Sisk
the corner of Siskel and Ebert oh and
Abbott and Costello movie did something
the city of Chicago hasn't done and
should we have an honorary Roger Ebert
way we have an honorary Gene Siskel way
they don't intersect Chicago get on it
I'm telling you there's a Gene Siskel
theater right across from the Chicago
theater and Ebert did everything he
could to save the Chicago theater rename
that so the right across from each other
and they can still deny the Zuzu Congo
theatres a lot bigger caught the Roger
sanam that pissin ng and Cisco's memory
but the Eber theatres better if you did
that it really would be like they're
right across from each other and they
would get direct competition if you
don't know the theater we're talking
about this is the one that's the giant
vertical sign that says Chicago outside
yeah the perfect strap is just gonna see
you beat me to it the perfect strangers
opening that's that's the theater we're
talking about he's so cool
Roger Ebert help bring that theater back
from the dead again no yeah I know Cisco
leave in Chicago now as an intersection
we'll make it a pile of the I love the
bit it's both so super silly but I think
it just kind of works cuz Saito is just
selling it with the way he walks but
that whole thing's like let him go for
when the dichotomy of him taking the
long walk versus yeah dread getting
defrocked or whatever yeah let it be
stripped from the records of it and that
was a met her she yeah yeah it's like so
Connie but in the context of the movie
it just works it's like I just always
loved it is it as soon as you mentioned
that the first thing came my hair her
just oh that is that is the face of like
you're in a fight with your girlfriend
and you just pulled out some a bomb of a
comment or you bring up something like
maybe your mom was right just turn to
you like
it's just a great face i but by the way
the music in this movie trying a million
percent on more than it has to it's
actually a challenge so it's a great
yeah yeah I mean usually does great
music anyway but I mean this is just
going way above and beyond
you just watch singing along with it I
am now though I am no the law I know
that all tread tread he is neat just
read it's memorable like like back to a
future you want to sing you know lyrics
to that and stuff you want to sing
lyrics to these it does have that back
to the future quality of just making you
just want to hop along on this adventure
yeah I mean it's I think that plays a
big part weavin that stupid scene where
it's just if you're just to show the
footage of this of Stallone you know
going out it's like okay it gets us
trying to look big but the music just
makes it look like you're watching the
it's just huge I think that's always one
that goes on this list of great scores
two bad movies like oh yeah oh but yeah
it's it's dumb it's terrible I love it I
love it it's good it's my judge Jimmy
Jam yeah it's so good yeah anything else
about it just feels like a checklist of
all the cliches at the time oh it's so
nice it's very 90s yeah I mean just the
comic really if you know what it doesn't
relieve the the stone-faced muscle-bound
Stallone guide the credible actor it is
a 90s film spoofing gritty eighties
action movies is what it feels like to
me like not spoofing like this was our
intention but it feels like what the 80s
was doing with its action films like
Robocop has now de volved but
entertainingly so into this where it's
there's there's definitely a higher
budget and like the the effects are
really good and everything but it's like
there's kind of a cheese factor to it
like it's nowhere near as dark yeah
which is ironic cuz it's shot very dark
and when you think about it I guess dark
stuff happens but it's in such a goofy
way in the
so goofy that you know I I feel like
they kind of probably want to do kind of
like a darker action flick especially
because this came out the same year as
Batman Forever so they're probably label
will be the dark big I'm basket was a
pretty silly I felt the same way about
demolition man I was like that was
another like this and wonder if both
films were like in production hell in
the eighties and really more demolition
man I've wondered shit man was so
consistently funny and not not even
genetically it was like should I feel
like but I probably know demolition man
demolition man feels like the Paul
Verhoeven film that never was cuz if
he's a Robocop dark satire vibe to it
yeah actually but Judge Dredd kind of
the Starship Troopers Bible ooh yeah
that quite as much competition if they
did with the clones like you were saying
like they're both leaders and stuff that
would have been Starship Troopers that I
consider the ultimate expression of that
90s like action cheesy yeah to win pop
star Seraph they're hoping themselves or
why do you think that film was in the
heavy suck I don't think people realize
it's supposed to be a comedy don't take
this seriously dear god no you're
supposed to not like them Dave you take
it seriously this is a fucked up like
message would you like to know more
oh I guess that was great we have
[Music]
reviewed Doogie Howser Gestapo agents
hey man like that was that was the
moment like grow up poison grass Neil
like Neil Patrick Harris III never had
anything against him I like him in
Doogie Howser but that was moments like
this guy is amazing because I hadn't
seen him in forever and he just shows up
I don't know we're in this movies like
grow up boys and girls this is war it
was a Dookie Howser just make me want to
shit that's a good rest is the villain
from Raiders of the Lost I never view
this soon hey guys we're segue discuss
to Bruce which means like you know what
I do it so yeah there's our thoughts on
Judge Dredd slash Darshan's slash
demolition man
Siskel and Ebert intersecting in the
middle of downtown Chicago Chicago
architecture something like that so
you